what does it stop Celine Dion singing  about mortality and how poignant those  words are now following the death of her  husband Rene Angelil so he lost the love  of her life just months after recording  this emotional new ballad the heart of  the man has he grows  the song is for the animated movie snow  time a remake of a french-canadian  classic I did discover the movie because  of my son Rene Charles and I think the  first time we watched a movie I don't  know maybe he was around six eight years  old roughly it was pretty touching both  the film and the soundtrack are out  February the 19th this song hymn was  recorded while Rene was at homes  fighting cancer I still feel that  origins and those values um and I want  to pass them along to my children  you